this was the scene that confronted the
emergency services an incident in the
heart of the city on a busy morning in
broad daylight and good weather
a man drove his car into a group of
people here at townsend strasse at 10 30
local time injuring several people the
man then returned to the road then came
to a stop in a shop window
some of the casualties were children and
teachers from a school in the western
german state of hessen
the driver of the car was held by
onlookers until police could arrest him
he is described as being 29 years old
with dual german and armenian
nationality and lives in berlin
there's no real confession letter what
we are doing now is examining the car
apparently there are posters inside
i haven't seen them myself but
apparently there are posters where he
talks about turkey
forensic investigators have examined the
scene of the incident trying to build a
picture of the exact sequence of events
scenes like these bring back the memory
for many people of what happened near
here back in 2016. when a man hijacked a
truck and drove it into a crowd of
people at the christmas market that's
usually held in this area
in that incident 12 people died and 56
more were injured
casualties on that scale have been
avoided in this incident and police were
able to take this driver into custody
dominic kane al jazeera berlin